today's one minute Monday is don't be
afraid to try so a couple of weeks ago I
did a famous Friday profiling Elon Musk
it's a great story and Elon is one of my
favorite entrepreneurs now I've done a
lot of stories of famous entrepreneurs
over the years and I wanted this one to
be special I wanted it to really have an
impact on people so I thought I'd try
something different I thought I'd had a
lot more stats and figures and data to
the story to hit the point home a little
harder I spent more time on this one
video than any other video in probably
two years and unfortunately it sucked
now a lot of you guys still had a lot of
great things to say on it
left lots of thumbs ups and comments on
it and I really really appreciate you
for that but in my mind it still sucked
because it didn't have the passion and
energy and excitement that it usually
does because I was so focused and trying
to remember the stats and data and
figures that I couldn't get the
excitement out in my voice but I put it
up anyway because when you're trying
something new you're gonna suck at it
you're launching a new product a new
service trying to make a new youtube
video you are going to suck at your
first version and with practice and
practice and practice you'll get better
so don't be afraid to experiment don't
be afraid to fail don't be afraid to try
because it's to do trial and a lot of
failures that you'll end up achieving
your dreams believe for those of you
watching like this video subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you soon
so a couple of weeks ago orbited Abba
Dabba Dabba Dabba Dabba did so a couple
week so a couple weeks ago I did a
famous famous Friday sign up for the
newsletter for more belief
you